- Honorary Oscar to anyone.
Hmm.
(bright music)
- I would give an honorary
Oscar to Ruth Gordon,
the actress in "Rosemary's Baby,"
the most phenomenal
performer of her generation.
- Winona Ryder.
I love Winona as a person,
and also she's been in
so many iconic films.
She means a lot to me.
- Angela Bassett has done some
incredible phenomenal work
as an actor.
She's part of the reason
why I want to act.
I just want her to have that moment.
- An actress who actually
opened a lot of doors
for other black actresses in the UK,
and her name is Carmen Munroe.
I just sort of feel
like I wouldn't be here
if she wasn't there.
- A drama teacher called Hillary Wood
who trained actors at RADA
and the Lir Academy where I went to.
I feel very grateful to
be one of her pupils.
- To my high school English
teacher, a guy named Crag Hill.
I don't know if I would've kept writing
if it weren't for him.
- I'd give an honorary Oscar to Zelensky.
- I'm not gonna beat that.
- [Carey] What a hero.
And he's an actor.
- [Zoe] There's a humanitarian award.
Yeah, so that's him, Zelensky.
- Honestly, my wife.
How could I tell her how
much I appreciate her?
- I would think of
someone who's been working
for a long time.
I would have given an Oscar to my parents.
- I'm just keeping it a hundred.
I'd give it to my momma.
My brother Edwin and I,
we started in this game
when we were both three years old,
and Mom is the one who pushed it.
If ever there is a day
that I ever receive,
you know, an Oscar, I
would definitely dedicate
and actually give that to her
because she deserves it the most.
- I would give an honorary
Oscar to John Waters.
- [Luke] That's a really good answer.
- He really deserves one.
- For her future work,
which I have no doubt will
be incredible, Sarah Polley.
Maybe she'll get an Oscar of her own.
- [Billy] I think she's
gonna get an Oscar Oscar.
- [Luke] She's getting
an Oscar of her own.
- Christine Vachon for
everything she's done
for American Independent
Film and New York Film
and queer film.
- David Fincher, Michael Mann,
because they're iconic American filmmakers
who have completely set
the tone of amazing movies.
- If I could give an
honorary Oscar to someone,
it would be to David Lynch.
- [Interpreter] Randa Haines.
She directed my first film.
She was the first woman to direct a film
that was nominated for an Oscar.
- I always feel that Ozu
deserves an honorary Oscar
because his films are
so beautiful and elegant
and so different from Western Cinema.
- Athol Fugard, the great
South African playwright,
who also, many of his plays
were made into very great films,
some of which he directed himself.
- Athol Fugard.
He's just this complete
underrated, brilliant
Tony Award-winning,
Telluride-celebrated living artist,
and I think it's his time.
- If I could give an honorary Oscar,
I would give it to the crew.
There are a lot of people who are there
before we get to work
and who stay there after we get to work
and who make it possible for
us to do the very best work
that we are capable of doing.
I wish we had more
opportunities to thank the crew.
- I personally would
give an honorary Oscar
to all the public who
are returning post-COVID
to movie theaters
and making movie theaters the experience
we all want 'em to be.
So that's millions of Oscars,
but I think every one of them deserves it.
(bright music)